hey everyone david2 here and i'm excited
to be back to share some updates on our
new ga launches for load balancing and
service networking stick around
[Music]
we'll kick off this video discussing new
features available for both internal and
external https load balancer
this feature enables you to test url
maps that has already been deployed
as a refresher a url map is a
configuration resource that routes
requests to backend services or backend
buckets
for example example.com video can go to
one backend service example.com audio
can go to a different backend service
and example.com images can go to a cloud
storage backend bucket not only can you
use url maps to route traffic based on
the path but you can also route based on
the host
this flexibility is crucial for traffic
engineering but could get overwhelming
in validations
with this launch you can easily
configure tests to verify whether a
specific url are hitting the expected
back end when running a test we will
identify the backend you expect versus
the backend that traffic will actually
be routed to
moving on to the internal network load
balancer we have several updates to
share we'll start off with an
enhancement when using the internal
network load balancer as the next hop
for routing
for context
you can create a static route which
sends traffic to an internal network
load balancer as the next hop
in this example when using an internal
network load balancer to balance traffic
between multiple nat gateways that route
traffic to the internet
this was available only for tcp and udp
with this launch we now support all
protocols which allows for more
functionality and easier troubleshooting
next feature is something crucial when
deploying stateful virtual appliances in
google cloud symmetric hashing
prior to this launch whenever deploying
stateful virtual appliances in a highly
available manner it would require
sourcenet to ensure the return traffic
would be properly routed back to the
same appliance with the launch of
symmetric hashing we simplified
operations for stateful virtual
appliances by guarantee traffic of the
same flow gets the same hash
in other words the hash doesn't change
when the source ip and port is swapped
with the destination ipn port
this ensures the return traffic hits a
corresponding virtual appliance and
removes the requirement for source net
lastly for the internal network load
balancer we've added some functionality
for udp protocol session affinity prior
to this launch only tcp sessions
supported two tuple and three tuples
session affinity
now the internal network load balancer
can ensure udp connections from the same
source and destination ip or source and
destination ip and protocol go to the
same backend instance
saving what i'm most excited to share
for last private service connect private
service connect enables private
consumption of services across vpcs
belonging to different groups teams
projects or organizations
it is simple scalable and secure since
the traffic never goes over the internet
you may recall my previous episode
covered private service connect for
google apis
that update allowed users to create
custom endpoints for google apis
this update is to use private service
connect to publish and consume services
private service connect solves many of
the caveats that current private vpc to
vpc solutions like vpc peering introduce
with private service connect ip
addressing and iphone usage is
drastically simplified
consumers and producers don't need to
share quotas and limits and it allows
for overlapping addresses between the
vpcs private service connect also allows
for multi-tenant services
this means different consumers can
connect to a multi-tenant service
with private service connect producers
can significantly scale in a private and
secure manner
this gives flexibility to a sas provider
as it enables easy and secure private
connectivity
and that's a wrap for this episode of
what's new in networking thanks for
tuning in to learn about our new load
balancing and service networking updates
make sure to take a look at the links
below stay tuned for the next episode of
what's new in networking
[Music]